most people should not be out there
trying to build the next facebook and i
think it's kind of up
that a lot of people try to tell people
that's what they should do
most people want maslow's hierarchy of
needs right you want your family taken
care of
you want food on the table you want to
be able to do the you want to do on
the weekends and that's it
and so i like the portfolio actually
better of a portfolio of small bets
i think of buying businesses a lot like
i think about buying stocks
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
sam you showed up i thought uh i thought
you were too hungover from last night's
pod that went till two in the morning uh
to show up today
dude it went later for me i mean i
didn't go to bed till four what time did
you what time what time was it
over for you it ended but my brain
didn't turn off so like i don't even
know if i slept last night i straight so
we
so cody we had um biology on the pod
yesterday
and uh i don't know if you know how yeah
kind of a real smart smart dude and
he definitely um you know has like a ton
of different ideas and thoughts and he's
like super super smart on a math
perspective science
uh you know technically for computer
science uh and so he was you know
rattling off a bunch of interesting
things but when he left and i'm going to
sleep and it's just you know
you know i'm sitting there i'm in bed my
dog's in the bed and like
my mind is like making up a straight up
i was just making up like scientific
theories in its head like
you know that state where you're
dreaming but you're you're like lucid
dreaming or whatever you're like kind of
like half asleep
and so i was half asleep but my mind was
like oh but then the vector has to go to
the scalar and then it has to
you know the order of magnitude and i
was like then i'd wake up what the
am i talking like what the is going
through my head this is not even this
gibberish this is a scientific gibberish
and that straight up happened like the
whole night so i'm not a great be
prepared to be underwhelmed in
comparison
to him today i think is the moral of the
story
well he uh he's just like
like we've had a i think we've had one
other person on the podcast like i guess
michael saylor could be this
but i i for sure think that uh rahul
from superhuman was like this
but there's like these a handful of
people who we've talked to and you know
people say like oh that person's a
genius
they're not they don't really mean it
but if we define genius as just like a
certain iq
i would bet a lot of money that that he
was the highest iq person that i've ever
had a conversation with and it was very
obvious
and he actually was quite he tried
really hard to hide it
in that he tried to act nice and
friendly and
there was times where he was like sorry
you guys probably don't understand that
let me try to re-explain and that was
that was actually pretty cool
but he just his he's just smarter than
me like his
he's his oven just burns hotter and i
there's nothing i could do
to try to understand that like i
remember one time i didn't want to
embarrass sean but like
biology was telling something and he
used up he used math metaphor he's like
he's like what i try to find is the dot
product between me and this and i was
like dot product i remember that like in
eighth grade i heard this phrase 15
years ago didn't understand it then
never ever thought about it again and
then he's referencing it for like
the way he thinks about something he's
like you know so i try to find the dot
product and i was like
i don't know what that means wait
but he what like he went from math
so he was talking about math to talk
about an idea and then he moved to like
uh this one battle like some type of
chemistry and then he went to the battle
of the balls and he goes to shot he goes
sean you know like you know like it's a
battle of the bulge right um
and john was like yeah and he's i don't
think he knew what the battle of the
ball was
yeah anyway it was an interesting
podcast
but this
could you imagine how like you felt like
that last night sean could you imagine
being in his head
every day or at like a dinner with
normal people he probably wants to kill
himself
yeah we were we even asked him about
that stuff uh we were like you know
we asked a whole bunch of questions that
were like i hope not even like
condescending but we're kind of like
were you always like this and like
what did your family think like were you
like an oddball to them or are they like
was this like totally normal because
i've never met somebody like you so i
want to know like
what's your life like what do you do for
fun like uh you know how does this all
work
and so we asked him a bunch of goofy
questions like that actually
unfortunately the best the very best
part was at the end after the recording
ended and we just kind of
after a three and a half hour podcast we
then shot the for like 30 minutes
and it was great and his guard was
totally down and uh that was awesome and
then sam started helping him with his
newsletter tips and he was like taking
notes
and he was like oh this is this is great
this is awesome stuff and like
that was ironically the best and
simplest part of the podcast and
we have like three and a half hours of
like good stuff but in a
i mean the way you said it his oven
burns hotter than ours uh and so you
know i didn't feel like we were able to
really
add too much to the conversation or
really like steer it because i was like
riding a bronco that i didn't know how
to
ride basically it's too smart for me i
love that
can't wait to hear it anyways so uh with
that
out of the way welcome to our guest uh
cody's
cody's here so uh cody i guess like
how do you explain yourself uh when you
kind of introduce yourself because you
have
a newsletter that's pretty cool you know
uh
this country and cash flow newsletter
you have an investment uh fund and
business there
you have built and owned businesses i
think majority share in some businesses
so like what do you
how do you describe this jack of all
trades so hi i'm cody
here's what i do what do you say well i
think if i'm on an airplane sitting next
to somebody i usually tell them i'm a
sales person so i don't have to talk too
much
uh but in a conversation where i was
trying to impress somebody
you know i'd probably say i'm an
investor i
am a private equity investor i run a
fund that's about a couple hundred
million bucks focused on cannabis
before that i did emerging markets
couple billion dollars raised there
and and now i write about all the things
i wish i knew
when i was first figuring out anything
to do with this green language of money
and i do that at contrary in thinking
and i mailed the two but i think these
days that's not that weird there's a ton
of vcs
not so many pe investors out there
probably that
write about investing and share their
ideas and i kind of think that's
probably the future and where it's going
going forward
you you i didn't know that i knew that
you had the newsletter
but so you have you run a 200 million
there's five partners but yeah we have a
200 million dollar cannabis
private equity fund we invest in
companies that do like 10 to 50 million
dollars in revenue largely it's called
entourage effect capital
and uh we've invested in 67 companies
thus far
some cool ones um that you all would
know i think there's been six unicorns
in there thus far so
you know um you guys maybe know gti
green thumb industries acreage canopy
growth
uh cura leaf i don't know if you're big
weed connoisseurs you know them
and then uh and then we have a smaller
fund that's about 20 million bucks
that's for micro pe
so that's just me and a couple other
partners money where we buy small
businesses
and that's if if we'd sort of fancy and
not fancy i guess trendy uh then the
other one are super boring and
things that you know your your father
did when you were growing up and you
didn't tell people about
and that's like uh give us examples
we're talking laundromats we're talking
um what are we talking about plumbing
businesses what are you looking at
actually the first one was a plumbing
deal we started it because my uncle ebb
uh he had a five million dollar business
let me make sure i get the numbers right
that was doing about two to three
million dollars in profit and he was old
you know
70s ish and he was a shared crop he grew
up in a sharecropping family
um didn't know anything about the
business world
and when he came to uh retire he didn't
know anything about m a so instead of
selling the company he basically
just wound it down and uh and you know
he took a company that had two to three
million dollars in profit and just
just you know let everybody go and and
sort of wound on the business and i
thought that was a real waste
and so um we realized wait a second
there's actually like a business model
here it's called pe
i've been doing it for 12 years at
goldman and vanguard and state street
and all these different firms
why don't why don't they apply this to
these micro sized businesses anything
below three mil
and uh instead of us making a bunch of
money for other people we could make
money for ourselves
so we ended up taking an offshoot of ebb
homes plundering
you can look it up it's in phoenix and
we bought a another plumbing company
rolled it in
sold that one that was a little tiny
company and
and then i've done it for a bunch of
others and now we own laundromats we own
a podcast production company
uh we own some lawn care businesses we
own
a professional services business it's in
the cleaning space
so a slew of tiny sort of boring
businesses and most of the time
i don't operate any of them there's
somebody else that's an operator in them
or we place somebody in the business
uh we love this model me and sam both uh
a couple of our best friends
started a kind of micro pe firm we
invested in and i think have been
i don't know sam i don't know how how
closely you track them but we've been
i've been learning a ton
as they look at all these different
deals and it just seems like there's a
huge generational shift of
people who are aging out of their
business and need to hand it off the
kids don't want to take it over
necessarily or
aren't able to or whatever and so
basically the boomers handing over
businesses there's just like all these
businesses that are beautiful
five fifteen million dollars a year
profitable
super steady book of business um and you
can you could buy these out
like super yeah
it's like a 65 70 year old mom and dad
whose
kids went to a good school and they're
like
uh i'd rather work at facebook than run
the moving company please
i don't want to do that uh so and
they're like
all right what do we do now 100 uh and
that's what these guys are buying it's
going great
uh like i get their updates they're
making a lot of money and so
yeah good for me can you can you draw a
quick line so like let's do a quick
uh hop through the resume because so
people because i think where you're at
now is super interesting anytime i meet
somebody who's
in a really interesting spot now i'm
like how the hell did you get there uh
so you said something like goldman but
like
without going into the details of like i
did this and here's how it went just
sort of like
i went to school thinking i'd do this
first job was here second job was here
third job was here now i'm here like
can you give us that shirt and sweet uh
so i went to school
totally unrelated to anything financial
i'm not really a finance nerd at the
core
um i started off in human uh trafficking
and drug smuggling as a journalist not
doing it
but along the u.s mexico border so um
so i was covering things like uh you
know
old people being left behind at the
border and
um you know went with a couple coyotes
and actually saw what the process was
like
and anyway super young at the time i
thought i was going to change the world
to realize like ah
you know britney spears shaves her head
and nobody cares about these stories so
maybe there's a different way
and so anyway uh so moved from uh
journalism
to had my little quarter life crisis and
decided that maybe i wanted to
understand finance because my last name
sanchez
all these people's last name was sanchez
suarez whatever the case may be and i
was in a very different position than
they were
so i was like what's the difference why
are they there and i'm here and i think
the only
difference is green it's not actually
even that i'm american and so
went to from there i got recruited to go
to vanguard accelerated development
program saw a bunch of parts of finance
didn't understand any of it but
journalists we asked a lot of questions
so it's pretty decent at that
so asked a lot of questions got from
vanguard they're all about passive
investing right so create an
index that was at the very beginning
etfs
and create an index and replicate and
replicate and replicate
and i thought that was cool but not that
sexy or fun so i went to goldman
and i wanted to understand active how do
we do ipos what do these alternatives
look like because they're more margin
that went from gold men to state street
ran
international investment business for
state street at the time
and then left did a jv with a company
called
first trust and built out their
international portion so i grew the
business to a couple billion
in latin america and uh and basically we
sold
products to big pensions sovereign
wealth funds etc
and then after that business i was ready
to exit
myriad of reasons and looking for the
next emerging markets
uh and i started invested in cannabis a
few years back but real quiet
i wasn't sure my mom would approve and
uh and then went full in as a partner
into eec
what's your um um what's your heritage
you said that you're
are you i you're talking about the point
my father's half
so i'm half spanish half mexican are you
catholic yes
me too so a mexican catholic mother
probably wasn't a fan of uh oh yeah she
was thrilled maybe this baby's a weed
financier she was really excited about
it
um just making daddy proud but um you
know
i think once we kind of understood i
mean here's my pitch on cannabis but
once we kind of understood
the you know psychoactive portion of it
and the benefits for those who are
overusing opioids like i got her around
to it
but certainly up front she was not
thrilled about that but that's when you
know right when people think you're a
little crazy for doing something there's
usually
at least some opportunity left otherwise
all the smart people would have moved
first and i'm
not smarter than anybody else i'm just
better at maybe finding some early
emerging markets people won't go into
yet
and i thought you would be a great guest
for two reasons a i went on your thing
and you were so prepared uh
i'm not anywhere near as prepared for
this as you were for me unfortunately
but i
knew enough which was like oh she's
great at talking and uh
which is like half the battle and then
the other half is like oh wait she's
like
wicked smart with a bunch of industries
that i think people don't know a ton
about so micro pe i know there's a lot
of people interested but
for most people it's a little bit
daunting they don't understand how to
identify the business how do you value
them how do you buy them what do you do
after you buy them that sort of thing
and then same thing with cannabis uh
people kind of know it's a big market
but don't spend you know if you're not
spending every day in that world you
don't know how it's going how what's
what's been growing
and so you sent us a bunch of things so
you sent us
ideas on the micro pe side you sent us
ideas on the canvas side
and then you sent us some controversial
thoughts sam where do you want to
start uh of those three
uh the ideas particularly the she posted
something in trends about mailbox
mailboxes which so like you just have
like
five or eight different things that i
think are interesting
they're not like huge home runs but
they're
small business entrepreneur like stuff
that like an
immigrant who came from nothing like
would start and then eventually did that
for 30 years and they would have like
a empire let's wrap it up let's
rapid fire them and here's how we'll do
it uh you sent us this bullet point list
i'm just gonna say the phrase and you'd
be like okay so here's what i'm thinking
and then if we just want to switch if
i'm like okay that's great i'm just
gonna throw another one at you and then
you go from there i think you'll be able
to volley these pretty well all right
let's do that one mailbox money what are
you what are you thinking about here
so this is pack and ship centers so
basically think fedex ups
except get rid of the franchise fees
because that's 25
of your your profit off the top and
instead you just put
you know sam and sean's shipping center
on the front of it and what this is
that i didn't realize my friend lisa did
it i'm always curious for my people who
make money in ways that are repeatable
since i'm not smart enough like biology
or whatever his name is to create the
next tesla
instead i just want a bunch of stuff
that cash flows now
um and so with this you know how
everybody's obsessed with storage units
like
everybody builds these storage centers
and that's been like a sexy thing
right and and that's really just a riff
on everybody was obsessed with
multi-family and apartment beforehand
they're like going smaller and smaller
and smaller
but still trying to get as much profit
as possible well that's what
packing ships are so essentially the
money is not
in the taping of boxes and the stuffing
of stuffing to make sure
stuff doesn't break it's actually in the
little mailboxes
in the front uh oh i was gonna ask you
what do you think of this po box rental
so at first i like the trend
which is you're buying a box of real
estate and you want like kind of these
low operation
you know rental units so okay self
storage but now you should
shrink the self storage unit instead of
being you know 100 square foot
little room you're shrinking it down
into a one square foot box that you're
renting out for 20 bucks
and what you were saying so let's just
do the bathroom quick on this you're
saying
200 boxes in a location roughly is that
right 200 would be what you don't want
that's ups fedex go a thousand
okay okay okay gotcha okay that now the
math works so a thousand boxes
average fifteen dollars a month of
renting out the po boxes
and how do you get customers to like
what does she do to get what is your
friend lisa do to get customers how does
she
acquire these po box tennis well i the
smartest way what i talked to her
doing she built the first one that took
a year and a half to become profitable
because she had to do what you were just
talking about
it's not really that complex of a
business it's ads so ppc
it's dropping actual hard mailings in
the surrounding neighborhood
it's things like she does like a book
set up out front
little pop-ups for the neighborhood
where you can like you know free
packing if you ship this day all that
kind of stuff
those squiggly arm things you know that
you put outside of a new unit
all that stuff and then uh she
uh but but the second store i told her
to buy
and so what she did is went out and
bought an already an existing store that
had
customers and then just up sold them and
that's a much easier way to do it
and so you buy the store for about two
to three x profit her second store she
got for about 1.5 x retiring
uh owner and then she was able to take
that business and sort of
double the revenue for that one uh i
like this idea i actually might steal
this idea because
um i just rented out a big warehouse for
my wife's uh
business and one thing we could do
is just put a bunch of these mailboxes
in into that space
and uh and just actually offer this as a
sort of
a simple way to take advantage of a
small footprint of real estate
yeah i think you have to decide what
type of human you are like if you are
the type of human that has a
capability to build up a really big
business and that's what you in fact
want to be a ceo of a puzzle or
to be a ceo of an even bigger company
then i think the roi
on that is potentially more interesting
long-term you're not going to get the
same type of multiples with these tiny
businesses
but here's the thing most people are not
like the three of us
and i don't even know if we'd all be in
the same category we're all different in
the way we've built things
most people should not be out there
trying to build the next facebook and i
think it's kind of up
that a lot of people try to tell people
that's what they should do
most people want maslow's hierarchy of
needs right you want your family taken
care of you want food on the table you
want to be able to do the you want
to do on the weekends and that's it
and so i like the portfolio actually
better of a portfolio of small bets
i think of buying businesses a lot like
i think about buying stocks
so how can i get a little portfolio of
them with somebody running or operating
them
so that my risk is diversified and
you're right it takes more time but if
what you're really going for
is i want to make you know two hundred
thousand three hundred thousand five
hundred thousand a million bucks a year
and that that is my goal not to change
the world
there's so many better ways to do it
than do a startup in my opinion
yeah i'm 100 with you on that uh i think
that build versus
build verse buy is so slanted towards
build because building sounds sexy
building sounds like virtuous it's what
the media talks about
and it's really unfortunate because i
know a lot of people that would have
been really happy with 250k a year of
profits
um and low maintenance low headache and
um
and unfortunately they get sucked into
either one of two paths it's like
i guess i'll do the startup thing
because i want to be entrepreneur i want
to be kind of my own boss
uh so then i gotta like do this from
scratch find product market fit like
damn that's hard
and the other path is like ah that's
that sounds really hard i'm just gonna
stick at this job
and um and you know i'll be an employee
for the next you know 25 years
and never really get that freedom
because i'm sort of on their schedule
i'm basically renting my time out to
this company
and so the the bypass versus build or
join i think bi gets criminally
underrated right now but i think it's
changing like we have andrew wilkinson
on the podcast a lot
and one of the reasons he's so popular
is that when he says what he does
there's a hell of a lot of people out
there who are like
i want to do that that sounds fun uh
that sounds like an easier path than the
one i'm on right now and so i think it's
quite
appealing yeah sam you want to jump to
one of these other ones that sounds
interesting to you we got
i see a bunch that i know you'd like
tiny homes buying distressed assets for
zero dollars laundromats which one you
want to do
oh no we got to tell you sam
the audio's gone again
okay
sam has uh peaced out the technical
difficulties have overcome him
and he cannot continue on he is he is
out of the game
uh okay i'll do one uh so i want to talk
about just buying distressed assets for
zero dollars
is this something you've done or why did
you bring this up on the list yeah
so this one is one i've done um and
actually there's an example of it i'll
give you the
actual example so i have a friend
brittany who owns a bunch of gyms
and not a bunch she owns two and they're
like you know like the gyms that um a
lot of women go to
where they have you know set classes and
you know they all get in and work
together it's kind of like women's
crossfit but
not with big weights anyway so she owns
a couple of those
like shapes without the franchise
basically exactly
so um she was telling me that a bunch of
her friends
their businesses pilates studios bar
whatever were going out of business
right during the pandemic and um what
was fascinating to me is she was like so
i'm buying some equipment you know i
feel bad for them i'm helping them out
i'm like
the way we got to do this is think about
those businesses they're going under
and they're worth now zero to the market
but they have value
so you know they're not getting anything
out of the client roster that they have
all the goodwill that they've built up
so what we decided to do was reach out
to some of these gym owners
and basically say hey you know i'm
really sorry i know you're going through
this terrible time what if we could help
annuitize you a little bit where you
could get some revenue
off of the business that you're about to
close for xero
and instead we can do a rev share
and so i own a business right now we'll
transition over your clients from your
business
to mine very carefully very thoughtfully
but give them a new home
and then for every client that we bring
over from you i'll pay you out on it for
a year
or i'll pay you out on for six months at
x amount and 24 months at y amount
however you want to structure it but
this way you actually make money
while you're closing your clients have a
new house and we have new clients and we
can serve them and we're friends and you
like me anyway
and so this business what to me what's
fascinating is nobody's doing this
that i know of like i if i owned any
business i would be out there right now
for every business closing on yelp sixty
percent of the businesses on yelp that
close temporarily close per
permanently so i would be out there
right now going after every one of their
client lists even if they were unrelated
and doing discounts and coupon codes
giving a rev share to the owner who
probably could use it
and taking their clients base and that's
how i would buy distressed assets i
wouldn't spend a dime
i love that i think that's great uh if
it's basically you're picking up the
assets and none of the liabilities so
you're not buying the business and then
having the rent and then
you know having to bring that business
back up you're basically saying what is
the what is remaining as an asset to
this business
um and it's the customer rolodex and i
think that's a that's a great one that
costs xero out of pocket from day one
it's just profit share uh
you know if if a customer does come on
over to you so i think that's a great
one
let's talk about um modular homes or
tiny homes i think you have a couple of
ideas on this so uh do you have one
yeah we bought a modular home which i
didn't even know did you know there's a
difference between
manufactured in a modular home there's
also weird terminology
no like i actually this is what i was
going to ask you is like i thought a
manufactured home is a modular home no
there are two different things i guess
so manufactured home
basically means it's what we think about
like stereotypically right it's a it's a
trailer home
basically all the difference is is that
there's no foundation set so you can
pick that bad boy up and you can move it
right that's manufactured
modular is that it's built in pieces
which is modular what that means but it
has a foundation so
at the end of the day there's really no
difference between a what is called a
stick built home
a house that probably you're living in
that i live in right now and
this modular home but the crazy part is
is well one we've all seen these cool
modular homes all over the place popping
up
but i was surprised i'm like they don't
really make sense
not at scale they're not that much
cheaper
and they're not that much faster when
you just drop one on your property
and i did a bunch of research asked a
bunch of people they're kind of sexy
but they're not that much cheaper but
when they are cheaper is when you do
them at scale and i was i was surprised
that there weren't any developments that
did this
and so i started scouring the country
found a few one in park city
and bought there and the numbers were
amazing and i bought it so i know
they're real
we bought our house for nine hundred
thousand dollars in park city
and um on an acre three thousand square
feet
the average price average or median
is like uh 2.5 million dollars in park
city
so the cost that they were able to save
was so amazing and they didn't pass it
on to the user fully i think they
weren't sure if we all were gonna
actually buy into this but the houses
are super sick
and i think that's a model if i was a
developer i'd be using those all day
long
and and i'd probably buy a modular
housing company
and then use it don't you think
right yeah and so when you look at that
home today can you tell
basically this is anything but a normal
home like is it aesthetically different
uh once if you didn't know coming in
what it was so i'll drop you the link
right now i'm not gonna say where
it is just in case anybody wants to come
yell at me about something stupid i say
online
um but uh i'll drop you the link and you
can see the difference but no it's
super sweet looking so it's it's kind of
the open concept
big windows whatever the case may be and
uh and you can't tell the difference the
only difference really is that
the turnaround time so we bought this in
december of last year or january
february i don't know and it'll be done
by july
and so it hadn't been built at all are
you going to add to it like
are you gonna have more modules to it so
i'm gonna add a back office like module
and then what we did is we got like five
or six of our friends to buy in the same
community
and they're cool looking and so i think
i'm going to do some event or something
and utilize the four or five of them and
then you could have it as a tax
write-off because it'll essentially be
like a little business
okay this house is sick and so the
company that's doing the development
they're
the company that's doing the development
here they are not the actual
uh manufacturer so there's three layers
right there's the manufacturing
level then there's going to be probably
some delivery layer and then there's the
developer who's doing a development
marketing that and then there's like
kind of the individual home buyer
uh beyond that so have you looked at the
manufacturers of this
yeah so that's where this one's
interesting the builder
and the manufacturer actually in this
deal together
so they do own the modular company
and at least a portion of it and then
the builder is one that's built this in
a couple other places they also have
another location that i think is cool
and also could work at scale which is
modular tiny
hotel rooms essentially and i believe
that's in jackson hole wyoming
and the economics are just so
fascinating because you know our modular
home will be built
in less than six months it's about a
third of the cost the square footage
uh if you break out by square footage
it's about a third of the cost
and then the part that's interesting is
in these locations where they're the
weather's terrible
you know and you can't break ground very
often they
um they build it all in a warehouse so
it's fine they lay the foundations all
in one period of time and then boom boom
boom boom
do all throw all the houses up as
opposed to everybody else in park city
has to wait like you know
two years or something like that so
we'll see but so far so good okay this
is pretty sick i like this one um
i'm gonna jump to more because i want to
see uh what these other ones are all
about so
talk to me a little bit about let's do a
couple of the controversial thoughts um
i'm gonna rip through them pretty
quickly and uh
and so let's let's do the first one
number one angel investing
is largely dumb is that painful because
we both are angel investors too
and you have a rolling pin no i actually
i actually say this
i say this often and people are like you
have a rolling fund and i'm like yeah
uh i don't of all my investment types
that i do this is i would say the worst
one but i think it's still good and fun
and i do it anyways but
i have like two or three better ones
than i do besides this yeah
so i think you know one of my uh good
friend's name is justin donald
and we're both pretty obsessed with deal
structuring
one of the biggest things i have a
problem with with angel investing is
it's it's too
fun it's like gambling right like you
get excited about the founders
and guess what founders are charismatic
that's how they raise millions of
dollars
and so you end up getting sold and it's
not their fault
and then you know there's fraud and you
know i wrote this whole piece about this
one guy that we lost to two million
dollars with
because he just was super egotistical
and like big images of himself on the
wall like all this stuff later that i
got added to my due diligence
questionnaire of like how many
images of yourself do you have in your
office but um
but the uh the thing with angel
investing is you know this you need like
20 30 40 deals for every one to four
that are going to go through
and so i think that the other thing that
we do a disservice is telling people to
invest in angel early on once you've
made a few million dollars and i mean
that literally
then i think go into angel investing or
if you're on a path
where you're making really good money
and you've made at least
half a million a million bucks then i
think you can start angel investing
but until then you know let other people
lose money and
learn from it you said it like you were
like take a
take a you know docusign image of every
deal you want to do write down how you
do it time stamp it so people can see
and then decide later on how good you
are at it without burning through a few
tens of thousands of dollars yeah
exactly uh okay so i have a bunch more
thoughts there but i
i largely agree with you and i would say
like it's one of those
here's my red flag is in order to talk
in order to justify angel investing you
have to give a blend of reasons it's
like well it's really fun
uh i like learning about the you know
the future and the mark and these are
all true things by the way so
it is fun you do learn a ton so
it's like an education
um you can make great money if it you
know pans out
as you assemble your basket you know you
should over a
you know you should you know be netting
you know a 20 plus irr
it just takes a long time it's a liquid
um and it's like not too much work
um because you're largely investing in
your network that you've already built
for 10 years like that's kind of the
thing and so there's like this blended
reason and anytime you have a blended
reason it
really means that there's not one really
great reason to do something um
and so those are always like you know
sub-optimal choices i find
for myself at least whenever i have to
come up with a blend and so
and because i tell everybody this around
me whenever they hear me justifying
something with a blended reason they're
like oh interesting so that's a
pretty big blend and i'm like oh yeah we
should just not do it never mind take it
all back
um because i'm giving you this huge list
and instead of just saying we should do
this because of x right like
we should invest in this business
because it's growing like like a weed
and if it wins it's going to be this big
that i can get behind
and some angel investors do fall into
that but the act of angel investing as
like a job or a hobby
is um is like it's more like when you
describe playing basketball with your
friends like oh it's great i get to hang
out my friends i get a good run in i get
exercise
you know i i you know it's i get
outdoors it's like you're giving this
blend of reason
uh for doing the the really fun thing
you just really want to do
and you're justifying it but the reality
is you just want to do it your brain
comes up with reasons
afterwards i think that's exactly right
yeah the only caveat i have to that is
if you can go
later stage deals which now you can do
with a lot of the late stage
uh angellist syndicates or if you can
structure debt
like if you can figure out a way where
you start earning interest day one
on a startup that actually has you know
it's a little bit later stage
and so it has some revenues or you could
you know get into a debt deal that's on
some of its
you know factoring of the invoices it
has like there's you know people always
think of equity with startups but lots
of startups prefer debt
so do debt with like a equity warrant
kicker on it and you can actually make
money
from day one and then have some equity
upside and that i think is interesting
but you know throw the y combinator term
sheet out the window because
it's not going to be on that
right um and all that being said i'm
still gonna
angel invest uh because it's because it
is fun um
and it's you know it's a hobby that
makes money so okay so let's do another
one public market
public market investing also kind of
dumb talk to me there well this one i
like to talk about a lot with big
investors
because if you look at the forbes 100
list there is not
one person on there who made their money
from just investing in the stock market
and then this is where people are like
cody warren buffett
carl icahn and it's like i remember i
was at goldman
in 2009 when do you remember buffett did
the deal
to invest a bunch of money in goldman to
stabilize it
yeah yeah so um i was there then
and it was not a public market deal
warden didn't go out to the street and
buy a bunch of stock he had a ton of
warrants
and options on top of it it was a total
backroom deal and that's the only reason
that he did it because he basically had
this huge asymmetric wrist right where
he had a bunch more upside than he had a
downside
and that's the same thing with icon who
tries to affect the outcome so
my point with people especially these
days with like games and all the madness
and stock investing is like
if you don't have an unfair advantage if
you can't like
write down why specifically you're gonna
win instead of somebody else
you should be really careful speculating
on stocks because
the big boys don't really do it uh yeah
i have a cousin who runs a hedge fund
and uh when he told me kind of like all
the different things that they have at
their disposal i was like oh okay i'm
i'm coming into a gunfight with like a
fingernail uh that's kind of like
how how uh lopsided it is and i so
you know so so that being said again i
think this is important to
say skin in the game here do you own any
public equities and
uh so despite this do you just do like
vanguard do you just say oh here's 10
companies i believe in i'm going to do
that or
what do you do yeah i don't hold any
individual stocks for
speculation purposes i invest in indices
and i'm not saying this is right or i'm
some guru
i'm just saying i don't think i'm smart
enough to beat the market and so i don't
play games
where i don't like the rules i'd rather
write my own rules if at all possible so
i go you know equity indices vanguard
you know whatever the case may be i like
vanguard the best
um and then i go uh mutual funds on
alternatives private equity reits where
you can actually have an unfair
advantage
but i don't speculate on any individual
stock now i don't i mean
would i own apple amazon facebook
whatever would i make a play on twitter
if i thought that might be fun yeah
maybe
um but i think there's so many easier
ways to make money with
private market investing and buying
businesses
as opposed to having to deal with the
irrationality of the crowds
right i mean do fundamentals really
matter
in today's world or is it whoever has
the best
ir and doesn't have some crazy thing the
ceo said or done
right uh yeah exactly uh have you ever
heard this term a keynesian beauty
contest
no what is that
so uh named after i think the economist
uh keynes yeah
basically the the idea is that this is
how the stock market works so a
keynesian beauty contest is where
you don't just uh send a normal beauty
contest you sort of just would assess
uh let's say the contestant that's
that's on the stage but in this case the
way the stock market works is it's not
you assessing the true beauty of the
thing
it's you guessing what other people
will value it at who are also guessing
what other people will value it at and
so it sort of is this like
extr you get these like really warped
things happen because
everybody is not betting on the thing
they're betting on what the other people
will do about the thing and everybody
knows that everybody's betting on what
the other people
will value the thing at and so you get
these like really crazy um sort of out
of whack things that that aren't you
know value investing
uh at its core yeah i totally totally
agree
let's do a couple more so uh buying real
estate at auction so a way to buy real
estate at a discount talk to me about
this one i've never done this yeah this
one's fascinating so
for instance let's use texas well sam's
in texas right but um i like texas
because they do this thing where they
actually
sell real estate at auction on the
courthouse steps
of each municipality or city previous to
it going on
zillow or redfin or whatever the case
may be like we've all seen those
are these foreclosed is it foreclosed
properties that you that you get there
or what what type of properties are
yes so foreclosed is really when
it's listed on zillow and redfin
and so that's sort of like this post
auction
step that's when most of us see
foreclosed properties right so you're
like oh no i know how to buy
foreclosed i can go on redfin if it says
foreclose i can buy it well
prior to that you have auctions which
actually are the bank
auctions of bankrupt properties or
foreclosed properties
but you get it before the street does
and then you can even front run that one
step further which is there's a list of
properties
that are going to go into bankruptcy or
foreclosure
and the list in texas you can look it up
right now it's called roddy's list
r-o-d-d-y-s and on roddy's list you buy
this list
it's cheap like a couple hundred bucks
and you can get the list of all the
properties that are about to go
foreclosed and then you can door knock
you can go knock on the door
because even though it sounds predatory
it's actually not
because if you go knock on the door and
tell this person hey
i'll give you 200 000 for the house that
you
are in foreclosure because you owe 50
that actually gets them
out of bank foreclosure and gives them
the extra money
that the bank uh was going to write off
for them
so this is buying on the action steps
and i did it with a friend of mine aaron
mitchusdeggi
who's a stud at it and uh and it's wild
millions of dollars of transactions in
cashier's checks happen
same day on the courthouse steps why
can't somebody bring that online so why
is nobody built basically the tech
platform that says great
we go to all the court steps and then we
you know sort of flash list these things
and you can sit at your lap i can
you know sean he's he likes this idea he
loves getting an edge
but he's kind of lazy and so he doesn't
want to go do all this stuff
um why doesn't somebody bring that
online maybe like roddy's list i guess
is an example of that
bringing that part on mine um what about
after that well i think you could
there's a couple things that you need to
do in real life like you have to
validate that the house exists
right and the the couple keys to the
actual auction game are that there's
some part that is just
you gotta walk the walk so you could go
and buy a house at foreclosure and look
at it on google maps but google maps is
an updated same day so that house
actually might have burned down last
week or
a month ago and i know somebody that
that's happened to or
the house if you look at it on google
maps you may not be able to tell
that the inside of the house or you know
the back end of the house is totally
blown out so you've got to kind of go
walk the properties a little bit
there's one part of it right and then
the other part is
it's about debt and who owns the debt
and like one thing i've realized about
wealth over time is
um debt is just about everything you
should always look for even before you
do a startup investment
is there any debt on the company am i in
a first lien does that you know
do i have first access to money if this
company gets it in some way
and it's the same with a house so a lot
of these times
they'll have a lien on the property
that's like this is weird
this is actually an interesting business
for you guys to look at like one of the
biggest predators
on uh low-income home uh owners
is you know those faucets like the
little water purification faucets
that you have in like your house yeah so
um oftentimes those are put in houses
by people that come door to door and try
to sell them to people
and and they use it by doing a lien or
applying debt to that person's mortgage
and so you could literally have a lien
before you for like 1500
that hasn't been paid so it's now worth
like 25 000
because the interest is 10 or 12 percent
and you don't even realize it
so you do have to yeah so you do have to
go actually figure out
who owns the debt on the house and you
do that again through a list like
roddy's list that will tell you who owns
the title
to the house but none of these are big
problems if somebody can list houses on
zillow like zillow now buys sight unseen
you could just have apis in
from roddy's list from the local county
uh location you could probably have
updated google maps locations
and all three of those things
triangulate to go online i would imagine
i like it um and uh roddy's list is only
texas or that's
only texas but there's tons of them so
usually you have to go to the county
registrar
and they'll list how often they do how
often do they do auctions so in texas
it's every tuesday
in california depends by city and county
but
one of the interesting things is like
the biggest buyers of homes in
california for instance
uh in in this downturn in my opinion is
going to be the government
because they've essentially made it
where if this is not your primary
residence
you cannot buy these foreclosed homes at
auction
which is a crazy change but in 2008
that's what happened all the pe firms
went to all of these little
municipalities and scooped up all these
houses and got them at pennies on the
dollar
the only thing that is true about this
is you need cash you got to pay cash
so these are you know you're coming with
a hundred thousand dollars in cashier's
checks to buy this house and an
auction and buy it at auction right
yeah wild and i gotta just attend one of
these to
to see how it feels
um okay we'll start we'll end on these
last two um
you wrote uh how to collect cool people
i don't know what collect means in this
case but is that a typo or did you
really mean how to collect cool people
i did mean that well actually i wish sam
was here because he would laugh at this
one but
um so one of the things that i think is
important for investors or vcs or
anybody
um i guess really who wants to be in the
startup game is
like how do you make a connection with a
human like you right so
you know we get to know each other on
twitter i kind of retweet you a few
times
but before the social media game
was there um how i actually met sam
originally
i liked one of his articles that he
wrote in the hustle years ago
and um and i just did some research on
sam and was like you know i just think
he's gonna
he's gonna do some stuff i don't know
what the hustle was small at the time
uh but i think i want to know him and i
want him in my rolodex in some way so i
could bother him about things
and um and so i found out what his
favorite candy was which is
butterfingers i don't know if it still
is now
and so i shipped him this ludicrous
sized box of butterfingers right just
like a ton of butter fingers
to the point where like he didn't have a
lot of choices except
to like call me back and say like you
know what
thanks um and you know sam really well i
mean he's not always
thanks and what the yeah exactly
exactly and so anyway so and then i did
that with another good friend of both of
ours noah kagan
except it was something about tacos at
the time because that's his little
shtick
and i sent him a shirt and so the whole
point here i guess was kind of like
people these days will say i'm sure they
say it to you well but sean you have
this huge network of course you could
raise a fund
this way or you know sam of course you
could do this you have this giant
rolodex of emails
you know i didn't have any of that at
the time i was in finance we couldn't
even have social media
and i think those are all excuses and
instead you should just
get kind of obsessed with the people
that you think are interesting
find ways to connect with them and you
can even do it in an old school manner
which
might work more today than ever because
dms and social media are
inundated and uh what's your uh what's
your next move so if the butterfingers
and the tacos are the pickup line
and that's great because i and and this
happens to me and i i always feel like
well you did break through the door like
i i see you
and i hear you and i kind of check you
out and i'm like okay cool
um but honestly like most of the time
when that happens
i don't like become buddies with them
and i think that's what they want it's
like
i sent you that shirt like i sent you
that thing because you said you said you
like this and that so i sent it to you
i'm like yes
i did appreciate it but like i didn't
necessarily go start like a bromance
with you after that so
uh what is what do you do let's say with
your follow-through what do you do in
those cases to like
turn that little like you know funny
just sort of like hey
love what you do i'm a fan uh here's a
bunch of butterfingers
uh what did you do to turn that into
more of like a peer relationship after
that or
what would you do yeah well i think a
couple things one you got to be doing
cool stuff to hang around cool people
rule number one right right so like
prerequisite
exactly yeah so like you know i don't
care if i was backing up a dumpster
truck
actually that would be i would probably
be doing cool things if i did that for
for sean but
um but you know you have to actually be
out there creating the thing to be
around creators so i think that's rule
number one
and it's to have the lowest expectations
humanly possible
right like i don't want anything from
sean i didn't want anything from noah
i just wanted them in my circle and then
to ping them sporadically with random
stuff so i think i got
noah like one of them his investments
that he did i pinged him
uh on it like he actually had a question
about something
else i he put it on twitter or something
and i sort of responded and said oh i
knew that person
so it was trying to serve them a bunch
of different times
and then after doing that continuously
which is very similar to what i do with
founders when i want to invest in them
they'll eventually be like cody just she
kind of solves problems for me or she
does interesting things and makes my
life easier in some way
and doing it without being too you don't
want to be a creep you know i think i do
think when i first
uh engaged with noah and i can say this
now because we're buds but
i think he was like is she hitting on me
like what's happening
here you know does she like me and i was
like no dude i'm married sorry
um so you know but also just having no
shame
like i don't have an ego i'm not trying
to prove anything to anybody
and i think that's important what do you
think what would work for you would that
work for you
uh yeah that that that's so so the thing
you said that that works for me is
first and foremost the ultimate
networking hack is be
interesting okay that sounds easy what
uh that sounds like okay i can't do
anything with that well no you actually
can which
what is interesting to other people is
somebody who either knows
stuff in an area that other people want
to know that that thing so if you're an
expert of a certain area cannabis
defy just be knee-deep in it and you
don't have to be like a power player
just the knowledge is actually quite
useful um the knowledge network or
be doing interesting things so if i see
you out there actually making
happen
in your field and it doesn't have to be
a big you know so you don't have to be
doing spacex like
we got to be doing something so what
doesn't work is the opposite
uh you reach out you ask me for
something you ask me for my
most valuable thing time um without
offering me any reason why i should give
you that time
and maybe i will anyways because i'm
just in the mood but like you didn't
help yourself by like
making it easy for me uh and lastly
you're basically saying
hey i'm kind of doing nothing and i
think if you talk to me then i'll start
to like do something or i'll know what
to do
yeah and um and that's not fun like you
know so what what do i like i like
people who are doing interesting things
and then they reach out or i reach out
either way doesn't matter
and in doing so they are like you said a
non-needy person
so they're happy to give they're happy
to chat and they have low expectations
one of the weirdest things is when
people start with like hey
big fan of what you do i know you get a
ton of messages but i
just wanted to put this on your radar uh
cool great first message
second message comes in like 19 hours
later
i guess you just don't even care um you
know
what's the point of of this anyways you
know like
um i really thought you were a good guy
but now i know the truth it's like well
what's going on like you sort of pulled
a 180 and now you're really
needy and desperate for some kind of
response and now you expect
things of me that i never ever offered
to you um so i would say like you know
just do the opposite of those bad things
so be interesting
uh don't expect anything in return uh
just give and give little bits don't
even give too much because giving too
much it actually creates an obligation
also
so just keep it really simple share
interesting things with the person share
life updates if you're doing cool stuff
and be useful if they're trying a
project give them some feedback help
them out
reach share spread the word tell a
friend whatever
and uh let them know that you're kind of
you know in their corner
that's all that it takes really to like
break through with most people
and then from there um you know it's
either gonna work or it's not and you
know that
that's fine uh not everybody's meant to
be friends with everybody and that's
okay
yeah and don't ask to be uh mentored by
anybody that's my biggest pet peeve i'm
like i can barely mentor myself you
don't want me mentoring you what are you
talking about
not to mention talking about an
obligation it's like wait have you
looked up the definition that means that
i am supposed to lead you
like on your path of purpose we don't
even know each other man
right so yeah i totally agree
uh yeah and somebody said this and i
thought it was totally spot on um
they said you know the easiest way if
you really do want a mentor
first first things first acknowledge
that seeking a mentor
is a advanced form of procrastination um
you think that you need a mentor before
you do the thing and in reality your
mentor
and all other people who succeed don't
use mentors as a prerequisite yeah they
find people along the way that help
but that's because they're just in
furious motion and people turn and look
who's splashing in this pool
and sometimes they go and they lend a
hand and you know when you need it
but they didn't sit around say well if i
get that mentor then i'm gonna do the
things
so that's the first thing it's a it's an
advanced form of procrastination
and secondly the way you actually do
form a mentorship bond is
you ask somebody for a specific uh
situational piece of advice so not just
what should i do but like hey i'm
debating between these two options how
would you think about this or
here's how i'm thinking about it would
you poke holes in that and then
then you follow up which is where 95 of
people fall off the cliff they get
advice and they don't follow up with
hey i listened to what you did or i did
a variation of what you did
and here's what happened uh people
actually love hearing that update it's
they're
they're gathering data points of like
what works what doesn't and it just
feels good that like
you close the loop you get some closure
on that that conversation
and then you just say and now here's the
next thing like that's that's going on
and you know some people will drop off
because they don't want to deal with you
and some people will give again
and then you do that the third time you
say hey here's what happened um and now
this unexpected thing is going on uh and
here's how i'm dealing with that
and by the third one you guys will know
either this works
um we have good rapport we see the world
in similar ways they complement each
other they kind of like my spunk
and i like their experience and like it
meshes and we should do this
um or you'll know by then that you know
this is not the right fit
and so how do that's how you organically
ease into having a mentor
rather than trying to put a label with a
stranger
and asking them to commit to something
that they you know don't really
necessarily want to do with you yeah you
nailed it
i also think this is like probably not
very pc but i think it all becomes
easier once you've achieved like a
little bit of financial freedom
like i think the less you're focused on
making money every day
and like uh you know being in that sort
of employee lane and you can
do interesting things with your money
that opens up a ton of opportunities so
i'm
i'm pretty big on like it's hard to be
ideologically free
it's hard to be time free it's hard to
really have any freedom if you don't
have financial freedom and like that all
means something different to us
like you and i might think that that
means x
big dollar amount where some people
might be like no it's just enough to
cover
you know the money that i need to pay
today but that's like one thing i wish
more people could think about it's like
how do you how do you really get
financial freedom so that you can do all
the stuff you want to do
um and then you know how do you get
critical thinking freedom
where you can actually learn to ask the
right questions here's the
bit of insight i've had uh the
realization i've had recently
because i worked for like a decade being
like financial freedom that's what i
want
uh and even more so i was like okay i
want to buy a house so that you know i
want i want to have enough or i can give
my mom a place because she'll have a
better life that you know if we can do
that and blah blah blah
and um so i thought financial freedom
that's the best kind of like that's my
goal right now
i think a lot of people are like that
and um
[Music]
and now uh that i kind of achieved a lot
of those goals
i was like okay uh definitely my goals
just got a bit kind of bigger
and uh you know it's not like and it's
true i definitely do like carry myself a
little bit differently and choose
projects and people differently because
i'm not like
i'm not in i don't need you for the
money but um you know so i don't need to
do this for the money i can do many
things
and money should probably come along
with all of them and i don't i don't
need near-term money necessarily
um so so there definitely has been some
benefits but here's the realization
i used to think about financial freedom
like if i get x dollars then for me and
my lifestyle that's
i'm financially free and then um for
another person they might have a
different dollar amount
which i think is kind of what you're
saying and i thought that you know as
recently as like a month ago
and then i met um a bunch of people who
have a way smaller dollar amount but
what they have actually also is
way fewer demands and desires about what
they want out of their life
um uh you know in a good way like
they're happy as is so they don't feel
like well i need x then i'm gonna be
like
happier yeah i'm super happy right now
and like great if i have more money like
i'll have other things but i'm not going
to have more happiness and so
um and so what i realized was that
financial freedom is actually just
it's an internal question it is not
about a dollar amount financial freedom
is when you stop
deciding what to do based on money
that's when you have achieved financial
freedom
and for some people it takes getting a
large amount of money so that they can
do that stop
for other people it's wanting less
and then they can stop because they have
less demands for money their
their total numbers lower and for other
people it's uh more like you know sort
of buddhist or monk like where they just
sort of realize
that it's actually uh an internal
attachment that they have to
let go of and then they are now free uh
the freedom is
is uh freedom from your own desire
to have more money and therefore you
choose things based on money
uh rather than the kind of mathematical
definition which is well you like like
there is also like a sort of technical
definition which is
you have enough money where even if you
earn zero income your investments will
pay
your lifestyle uh and you won't be sort
of dip
you know you're not dipping into savings
your savings are increasing at a rate
faster than your life burn
and there is that technical definition
but i realize i know many people who
pass that technical definition and still
aren't financially free
and it's because internally they have
not actually freed themselves from what
they need
uh uh from this idea of like well i
gotta do like
putting money first as the choice uh as
a choice of what to do
uh whether it's people who penny pinch
or people who choose projects
based on a financial return as the like
kind of core criteria
yeah anyways that's the sort of i like
that uh no
i think it makes a lot of sense i think
you know above a certain level
like i get a little obsessed just with
everything that's going on economically
in the world with people who
again like aren't maybe where you and i
are like
i almost think financial freedom might
have something to do with your skill
stack
like even if you lost all of your money
today or if i lost all of my money today
as long as i have put as much
relationship deposit as i think i have
of other humans that are doing
interesting things in the world
you and i are never going to be homeless
like pending catastrophic
issue right because you can go to some
of your friends and be like hey i'm
actually pretty good at copywriting
don't you see look at my twitter account
hey i'm actually pretty good at building
these businesses i've sold a couple of
them
so once you like get that skill stack
you're like i'm fairly confident
worst case scenario i can go call up
somebody and work for them
um so i think there's some mixture of
the dollar amount in your bank
what you need to pay not having a ton of
debt and then are you competent enough
as a human
where somebody will always need your
services
and and you know and i think that paired
with like what can you reason and think
for yourself is a pretty powerful combo
yeah don't uh totally agree i think
that's great so give us uh
we should wrap up we give us where where
can people subscribe to the newsletter
because it's actually
really damn good um and i don't say that
like actually i'll i'll say i would
probably say that anyways if somebody
came on his guess i'm like oh you have a
great newsletter
but i'll just kind of shout out that i
actually believe it here i'm not just
being polite uh but you actually do a
really great job and
you're like us you don't shy away from
the topic of money
um you actually lean into it you say hey
you know like
a lot of people are interested in making
money and a lot of people don't know
what's under the hood of these different
business models or businesses
and so like let's lift the hood together
and let's look at this how this engine
works and how it
what's good about it what's bad about it
and how you might wait make it work
we do that as a podcast you do that on
your newsletter and we are very like
simpatico as far as that that goes and
so
where can people find you and where can
people find the newsletter so they go
subscribe
thanks for the shout out yeah
contrarianthinking.com is the newsletter
uh and then it's cody sanchez cody
underscore
sanchez on twitter i think those are
probably the two places i'm most
rocking and rolling um and twitter man
i've really found that fascinating in
the last six months
i think we've finally figured out how it
works so apparently i'm a little bit
more a boomer than a millennial in some
ways
yeah there you go uh cool and we'll link
it in the description so if you
didn't remember those just scroll down
and click the links in the description
to uh to find that of the podcast okay
cody this has been amazing thank you so
much i would like to have you back on at
some point maybe we'll
break down a couple of the businesses
that you've either acquired or been
looking at recently
and i think that'll be a lot of fun but
thank you for coming i'm in thanks for
all the questions it's always fun
brainstorming with you
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on a
road less travel never looking back
[Music]
uh